[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by sonos
my good friends sonos how much do i love
these guys at sonos you love this it is
this is by far if you're going to get a
good holiday gift this is a great
holiday gift sono devices are all around
my house i've had them for years i've
said this before but before i even had
them as sponsors which they were they're
just recently sponsors uh i've always
loved sonos i talk about it with
everybody and people are like
people everywhere have sonos
and i'm not the only one that loves this
product they just make great products
and you know instead of having
receivers and speakers everywhere in
your house you can just have this little
device that has beautiful sound and
that's really what sonos is about if you
ask me it's like uh you know saving
space it's not the old days where you
need to have five receivers and a
turntable and this all that you know
it's like come on man uh sonis is
wonderful make the sound system on your
wish list a reality share the joy of
listening on sonos this season with
speakers and sound bars that are easy to
set up easy to use and all work together
so you can listen in any or every room
like i do and bring the family together
with incredible sound for everything
from classic carols to festive films
sonos works with all your streaming
services and control is simple with the
sonos app your voice using amazon alexa
or google assistant and apple airplay 2.
spoil the listeners in your life folks
with a gift that truly keeps on giving
treat gamers and movie lovers to an
immersive home theater experience with
the beam
keep your fitness loving friends
motivated with great sound for their
workout playlist with move and help
relatives relax with hand-free control
of their music and more on sonosuan you
won't be sorry i'm going to get ready to
be bombarded with emails because you're
going to tell me how much you love sonos
that is just a fact i love them i know
you'll love them it's a great holiday
gift go to sonos.com that's sonos.com
to learn more and wrap up your holiday
shopping you're listening to inside of
you with michael rosenbaum uh thank you
for for tuning in ryan thank you for
being here thank you for showing the
[ __ ] up thanks for having me sorry for
swearing right away just right off the
cuff just swearing [ __ ] hey i just
don't even swear that much do you think
i swear that much
no yeah i try not to
like you swear like the normal amount of
person would swear maybe for the new
year i won't swear as much but uh i
think you [ __ ] should though wow
another f-bomb from ryan teos
uh hey uh thank you for making our show
a priority thank you for listening to
our show if you're here for brandon
routh and uh i appreciate that but
hopefully you'll stick around hopefully
you'll like the show and go hey i got
something from this i like hearing these
conversations can that open reel and
you'll stick around uh the handles to
follow us on instagram and facebook are
inside of you podcast and on twitter
inside of you pod that's correct ryan
thank you so much and i really
appreciate when people watch on youtube
subscribe on youtube you can also listen
on spotify apple
tune in stitcher all that [ __ ] you could
listen and tune in right mm-hmm yeah so
yeah so you could listen
and on just about every platform it's
free it's fun i hope you continue to do
it spread the word it really helps the
show thank you to all my patrons if you
go to patreon.com inside of you and you
become a patron i'll uh message you
and um they get back to the show whether
it's 50 cents or a dollar or some people
are top tiers that get packages for me
every couple months that give a lot more
there's a lot of things on there it's a
great community patreon.com inside you
really helps the podcast so if you want
to help the podcast then do it
more importantly
if you want to help
people in need
echoesofhope.org
if you want to help homeless people or
i'm sorry foster youth this helps foster
youth i've been on the on the other i'm
on the board and uh we can use your help
so check out what they have and you
could donate you could do you know help
out they could really use your help also
foodonfoot.org
you know my good buddy rob danson works
in marketing over there and they could
really use your help the homelessness
that's going on in los angeles is is
shocking and if you go to foodonfoot.org
you can donate and you really help
people and it's such a good cause and i
just want to say that
also i have the inside of you online
store if you want to buy merch and stuff
like that small lunch boxes autographs
this and that go to the inside of you
online store use the uh
the code rosie christmas10
roscy
and that's it that's all i really have
to say about that uh
i hope you have a great freaking new
years
and uh we won't be having a show on
january 4th we're going to take one week
out of the year off but we will be back
the following week with a brand new
season of inside of you with michael
rosenbaum and ryan tans
yes he'll be here as well next season
are you excited for the new year ryan i
am uh
yeah the last two years have kind of
been rough ones so you know every new
year that comes brings you know
hopefully some new brings hope yeah some
optimism yeah because now that we've it
feels like we've i mean hope turning the
corner christ we've been through the
darkest part yeah but yeah yeah so i
mean every new year is like all right
well we could put the last one away
yeah put that in a little box
i think so too i think the box i think
yeah i think it's good to be optimistic
and i think it's also not uh ridiculous
to be optimistic i think things will get
better and
you just have to know that and also just
be good to yourselves uh why don't we
stop chatting and get right into it uh
he's been on before but uh i think this
one we even get a little deeper and i
really appreciate him coming back on the
podcast he's a great guy
and uh loved having you buddy so let's
get inside of brandon routh
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience look at that that's a nice
backdrop you have you have a little tree
the beginning of the podcast if we
started yet i mean sure why not
well if we started hold on i have to
start
hold on
you look very handsome by the way very
handsome hello everybody hello everybody
oh oh brandon you're here too i'm
brandon
what is that hello everybody
nice to see you hello hello i'm i'm
brandon and i guess well i guess this is
brandon also um oh very strange brandon
has a puppet brandon has a puppet he's
talking junior this is
no no i am
this is a brandon puppet um this is a
brandon puppet that my son made me for
my birthday get out of here are you
serious not my nine-year-old son yes
with
felt
and scotch tape
what a good kit how old is these very
creative first puppet nine
nine i couldn't do that now
they went to the the dollar store
here in vancouver to get
uh
decorations
and they had some craft supplies too and
courtney suggested oh he could do
something with felt and they was like
i'm gonna make a puppet and this is the
first puppet he's he's
he made look at that you've got shoes my
favorite my favorite shirt he's got on
here
what is your favorite shirt is that are
you kidding or is that your actually a
shirt no it's a shirt it's a shirt that
i wear a lot that's the shirt there's
got a heart on a skateboard um
uh and uh this is this is the brandon
round puppet so then i said wow
they said hey dad can you uh
oh where'd the paper go
can you um
give me an idea for a puppet so i drew
one i don't remember where my design is
but anyway
it's like a robot puppet so i drew him a
design and
color and everything to a t he made
this other one this is a second one and
then we'll be done with puppets but it's
pretty
cool look at your son making puppets
that he's a puppeteer
yeah this is bebop
he's the next jim henson
yeah
look at that and they're unique
yeah yeah oh yeah a lot of scotch tape a
lot of scotch tape a lot of scotch so
we're gonna get in a cold
courtney says there's something called a
cold glue gun which i'm not aware of um
shouldn't get him a cold glue gun which
you think could be safe enough to use
because i guess it doesn't burn you
because it's cold i don't know
so you've really uh enjoyed this
pandemic time with your son um you've
had a lot of time he's had a lot of time
it's got to be difficult with a kid
during the pandemic right
you know he
yes certain things have been challenging
thankfully we kind of tend to be an
indoor family in
in some ways
so it hasn't been uh
it didn't alter our schedule too much uh
just before we had spent a lot of time
at vancouver and we're we're back up
here again but
just before that pandemic when we came
back
um
because we're traveling a lot and in our
you know crazy schedules sometimes we
end up spending a lot of time together
uh when we don't have work or when we're
on hiatus
and um and the transition from
vancouver back to l.a led us you know
kind of being in our our house a lot so
the first couple months leading up to
quarantine we were kind of like okay we
got this already we'd already started
homeschooling because of the transition
from moving we were going to supplement
the year with homeschooling and then um
so we were kind of already
in that zone and then it
uh
leo is thriving in it and we we like it
to participate and be his teachers and
um you know it's going well who's a
better teacher who like if you have to
teach in math or science is it you or is
it courtney
uh uh i i do the math and science and
courtney does the english and social
studies yes
we could both and we both trade off for
each other
um
it just so happens that she's better at
teaching the english than i am i which
is which i had is an ego hit for me
because um
i was an english major for one year only
and i wanted to be a
writer if i didn't become an actor and
what happened was
i would get to
i would get too picky with i was too
much of a gratitude for the for the
english and for the grammar and when he
was starting to write
um and so that was becoming
inhibiting his his kind of growth and
expression
and now i'm better at now i understand
because i've watched her work with him
and she does it in a much better way so
so she does and she's great great
teacher anyway but but one of those
that's one of the reasons why she's
doing she's doing that and i'm doing
what i'm doing are you a patient person
because you know my father was just so
impatient with everything i did that i
chose i don't want him helping me with
my homework i'd rather fail i don't want
him to teach me how to drive a stick
shift i'd rather fail i remember
he just had no patience how do you not
understand this we just went over this
how do you not
know this
and i would get so frazzled that i
couldn't think straight uh are you are
you patient or you have is something you
have to just like learn with this as a
child i have to really be patient he's
not going to get everything right away
you know i i like to think that i'm a
patient person and i can be and i have
been with him
school is is challenging in it and
raising a child is challenging you think
you're patient
um
but that gets tested all the time in
various ways
um
and um you know i i i am mostly but with
the math
we had a real challenge uh
just going working with addition stuff
at the very beginning and i had to
realize
through uh courtney helping me
become aware of it because we lea and i
would leo and i would get kind of get
back in these back and forth like why
don't you i don't why don't you
understand this well i don't i don't
understand that
back and forth
um
every couple days and realized through
courtney making me aware of it that he
has a different brain than i do he
doesn't i have to speak to him in a
different way i can't the way i
understand it is not the way he
understands this so just giving him one
example of how to do it i'm like well
why doesn't that make sense
it doesn't make sense to him um
so i learned to ask him questions and
say okay i see that
this isn't making sense
what part of it doesn't make sense or or
what if we did it this way or being
curious about him
so i think often
like many things in life when you're
learning about how to be a better parent
you learn about how to be a better
person
and in relationship with
every relationship that you have
and um
my ego was kind of getting attacked that
he wasn't
understanding the way i was teaching him
and
is one part of it but also i wasn't
being curious about enough about
how he was engaging with the math
right and asking him questions and
understanding how he was feeling about
it or what was frustrating to him i was
just kept trying to like well do it this
way or what if he did it this way
instead of asking him and so you know
just
as a life lesson curious curiosity has
been something i've been working on
being curious about people yeah you know
um i think we probably talked a little
about a little bit about this two years
ago when i had john so thanks for coming
back but you know when you talk about
patience and you're dealing with a kid
but then you deal with the real world
and brandon being on set and brandon
having to deal with real real stuff
going on have you learned like i'm
always the guy on set that wants
i'm already i'm ready to work but that's
not how it works it's mostly winning so
do you have you have have you learned
over time
to adapt and sort of like go okay i'm
not gonna
i'm just gonna wait when they need me
i'm gonna do i wanna be productive i'm
going to do something else and what is
it that you do
ah
well i don't know that i'm that
productive off
when we're not shooting yet i used to
have moments where i was more productive
i go and read or
before cell phones became such a big
time suck and mental energy suck uh a
mind
avoid um i used to read onset but you
know the
question you're asking me so i don't
really have a great answer i talk to
people i try to you know be
be ready for the next
the next scene um
but but
waiting is
and
is a challenging thing for an act for
anyone but you know they set up that to
set the lights they have to set up the
um the shot and get the camera all this
stuff has to happen in order for us to
move on to the next
the next shot um so there's a lot of
waiting and sometimes you get brought to
set and they're not ready for you yes i
know those days a lot of you still hot a
lot of actors complaining oh why'd you
bring us to set if you're not ready and
isn't that
um me i've been one of them
sure all of us have probably all of us
have probably been there one time maybe
we didn't voice it
but we're thinking it uh and you know i
i
these days i'm trying to see all that
stuff in a more um
macro view holistic view of the whole
team
you know what
pretty much everybody's working
to their capacity as hard as they can to
get the job done nobody wants to be
there all day they want to go home see
their families they want to do their own
thing
um
and
just kind of
reminding myself that
we're all we're all a team
you know the crew the cast we're all
trying to make this happen together uh
for me to sit there and complain
is is bad energy right feeding off to
everybody else uh on the caster cruise
working so hard um
so i don't know if i'm answering this
question no you are you are you're
talking about patience and i'm saying
that i'm trying to see not just myself
in the in the picture but but everyone
else and that that helps me go right oh
well just calm down because you're just
one part of this whole mechanism yeah
they called you to set earlier
too too early so take a seat so go back
and sit down tell them you're going to
go sit down you let me know when you're
ready instead of just like silently
fuming and getting like well they called
us they should just let us go so much
energy is expelled or or you know when
when you're just always kind of like
upset about things that's what i learned
it took me years and years to learn but
like
you're not doing yourself a service
right now you're not doing anybody
else's service you're just creating
you're getting more fatigued by working
yourself up and expending all this
energy creating kind of toxic
environment yeah just ask for what i've
been learning to ask for what i need
to know when i need something and ask
for it within reason obviously
inside of you is brought to you by home
medics oh boy man do i need this talk
about you know a guy who's had like
eight spine surgeries and just
played sports his whole life homedics
sent me this massager ryan
that is just freaking wonderful it's
just it's so deep
and just relaxing they have sent me this
foot massager too they're just fantastic
at home medics and uh you know
you got to try these guys out they've
got a whole line of massage products
from a massage gun with built-in hot and
cold technology to a massage cushion
that lets you lie down or sit
sit up depending on your therapeutic
needs to a three in one foot massager
with vibrations so powerful it loosens
the muscles in your legs and lower back
and you can be damn sure that i'm going
to be doing this right after i'm done
with this podcast that's what i'm doing
but moral of the story homedics has
massagers that address your pain points
from head to toe you're talking to
someone who has a lot of pain someone
who deals with it has had problems his
whole life and i really truly love these
guys this is downstairs in my basement
you go down there i have my couch i have
my hometics massager plus they have an a
plus better business bureau rating so
they are a brand that you can rely on
join the millions of customers who trust
the home medics family to take care of
theirs so whether you're dealing with
chronic pain or just looking to help
your muscles recover from a workout
we've got good news right now if you go
to home medics h-o-m-e-d-i-c-s
hometics.com
inside and use promo code inside you'll
receive a free portable phone sanitizer
when you buy a hundred dollars or more
in massage products that's a 60 value
that's homedics h o h-o-m-e-d-i-c-s
dot com slash inside and use the promo
code inside for your free portable phone
sanitizer with a hundred dollar massager
purchase inside of you is brought to you
by fairway listen to this guys the
fairway meat department has always been
considered the backbone of their
operation what customers can expect from
fairwaymeatmarket.com
it's still hand cut by fairway butchers
to ensure
the best possible quality and it's the
same quality that they promised at the
counter now delivered to your home
nationwide i love getting a box of meat
there just they have this holiday
special i'm going to tell you about
where you're going to save a lot of
money and it's free shipping and all
that but i'll tell you fairway meat
markets quality meat comes straight from
america's heartland each and every cut
is done by their highly experienced team
of butchers to ensure you get the same
quality they put in every in-store
customer experience people love the wide
selection of products
fairway offers ribs to rib eyes pork
chops and beef tenderloin they have
every style and cut your kitchen can
handle and here's how it works you just
visit
fairwaymeatmarket.com you select your
favorite meat products stand by your
grill
waiting patiently
that's what i do get the gift this
holiday season that your friends and
family will not forget and this week my
listeners can get the butcher's holiday
collection
valued at 275 for just
169.99 plus free shipping when you enter
inside at checkout and let me tell you
what you're going to get with the
butcher's holiday collection package
two 12 ounce usda choice ribeye steaks
two eight ounce usda choice filet
mignons
two eight ounce usda choice sirloin
fillets
four eight ounce 100 full blood wagyu
patties
six eight ounce certified duroc boneless
pork chops and two pounds of private
labeled bacon that's more than a hundred
dollars off the best meat in america
this holiday season plus free shipping
nationwide that's
dot fairwaymeatmarket.com
fairwaymeatmarket.com
promo code inside and look for the
butcher's holiday collection codes give
free shipping site-wide as well not just
on the select package
how do you deal with i mean it could be
a stupid question but i mean look you're
on set a lot you're dealing with a lot
of different personalities there's got
to be times when you're like
my vibe doesn't really go with that
guy's vibe or that actress's vibe or
whatever or i don't really like the
director um
how do you deal with that is it
something you can just like kind of like
zone out and just so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna deal with this or do you
have a tough time um
do you usually work with do you have
people that you work with that you just
really just don't really enjoy working
with and you have to kind of pretend
it's pretend time
i think i've had a pretty
[Music]
been
um
pretty fortunate
opportunity i haven't had a challenge
very often
um uh i i've worked on i've worked on
projects where they they
they unfortunately didn't have skills
like from a from a whole like mostly
crew production and in where where it
was
super challenging it was very amateur
hour
type situation
um and i really had to just be there for
the day i really had to learn to be
present um not for the outcome right but
just to have the best day that i could
engaging with people that i did
appreciate that were there and just like
go okay that cannot be fixed i cannot do
anything about that um this is gonna be
a train wreck
but i can either be upset every day
that's gonna be a train wreck or i can
just go okay
i'm gonna work on being as present and
and in the moment and enjoy my
day-to-day as much as i can you know for
me
everybody knows if i'm not happy
every i can't hide it you just see it in
my
disposition my disposition is just like
especially if i don't like someone it's
hard for me not to to sort of not
challenge them but sort of just say
hey is is everything all right
you know i've always had that
personality where i want everybody to
like me i want and if it's the one
person that doesn't like me i don't
understand it and
some people could just be like i don't
give a [ __ ] i don't care about you know
i care about myself i'm gonna do my work
and that's it but i i come to work i
want everybody to have a good time i
want there to be a good energy i want
everybody to like me is it did do people
are you
when you're not happy do people notice
it
i think so because it's a dramatic
change for me
because i normally am
on set
i mean differently recognizing my
personas on set
and then at home
on set i am
i am a people pleaser i want to be
uh
i want to be i want to be liked i want
to be part of the team i i want us to go
you know um and i've had to look at that
too to see who am i
who am i doing that for right and and
that's whole like boundaries issue
um
but i think people know when i'm not
having a bad day because i i kind of i
wear it around and it's it's a it's a
fairly stark transition to me
um right now i guess being engaged being
curious about you
and
yeah
and being in and being in a
in a creative space but being in a
uh in a creative space really energy um
and then when i get upset it's very
internal and you know i'm making eye
contact mumbling
um
yes
i understand
to become more and more aware of that
side of myself
um because it's not it's a very petulant
like
uh my child self and also like
a moody teenager
um aspect of myself which really doesn't
serve anyone and is kind of gross
does courtney call you out on that is
she someone that can just call you out
yeah
um absolutely um
and so
yeah i mean yeah so so so people know
when i'm angry and i'm working to
understand when i'm angry too
and i feel like at the core of that when
i get into that kind of spiral
of
that turns me into
not hulk mode but but
pouty pouty angry mode um is uh is like
just not communicating right it's not uh
something is going on with me and i'm
not communicating properly to myself or
to the person who i need to speak
directly to about what's upsetting me
and that just festers
because i want them to know to come to
like them to apologize then to go oh
well i've been doing this thing i'm you
know silly or or hey can i talk to you
about this thing i want them to engage
but i have to i've learned learning that
i have to do the work to go hey you know
what i have to be i have to be the
person to bring this to you
because clearly you're not aware of this
now i have to find uh the proper way to
bring it to you so that you don't your
defenses aren't raised
aren't alerted and you can't you check
out from the conversation you can't even
participate
um and that's a tough thing but when you
work with people
or communicate with people these are
skills these are skills that people
don't learn these are things that we
need to be teaching kids about in in
school conflict resolution
how to deal with conflict resolution how
to speak to people instead of learning
trigonometry or whatever else you know
that rarely gets used in real life i
think it's ego i think it's ego usually
or an insecurity or something that we
carry that is has really a lot of times
nothing to do with
someone else i think you know like you
said you want people to apologize you
want somebody to approach you and that
just doesn't really happen so it just
festers
so it is it's about learning how to deal
with others it's learning i mean that's
it's very important as a child in your
adolescent stage to sort of
understand that and say hey it's a lot
easier to just say hey i feel like
there's a little bit of attention or
whatever but let's let's dissolve that
how do we do that that that takes a big
person and that takes it's it's very
difficult to wrap your head around and
it's taken me a long time to understand
that as well
yeah you know
we just
like i said it's not taught in school it
should be a subject that's taught in the
school
um
you know we had i remember we would have
the
the um the school counselor would come
in and talk about fuzzy warm fuzzy
feelings and cold whatever feelings i
don't know and we talked about emotions
a little bit but not conflict resolution
it wasn't it wasn't
something that happened every day which
it it
it really should be and that's the
beauty of
the privilege of that we have the
ability that we have to in homeschooling
is that we can we talk about this kind
of stuff all day long if there's a he
has a deeper question about something
that his
uh
social studies material isn't going into
we
dive into it
and
that you kids aren't getting that
individual
um
[Music]
individual uh time with a teacher going
in in depth all this stuff and families
are stretched to the
stretched
they're not as not as much family time
as they'd like to have to be talking
about all of these things but
but it's it's happening more than it
ever did before i mean you come you look
at the the evolution of society which is
a very intriguing thing to me and the
emotional
uh intelligence of society um of our
parents and then our parents parents
what did they know what did they
how were they treated what trauma did
they put on uh on on to your parents my
parents and then the trauma that my
parents your parents put on we all put
trauma to some degree emotional trauma
on our on our
on our kids unless we're really aware of
it
and it's only been in recent times that
people are going to therapy that are
talking about these things that we can
talk openly about mental wellness and
and seeing a therapist you're not a
crazy person for going to see uh uh a
therapist i know shouldn't even use that
word
but you know that to use the the
it's breaking this version of it
what's that you're breaking the stigma
it's like you're getting you're getting
rid of the stigma
yeah we're getting rid of the stigma of
that and
and so at one point i'm like so
frustrated at people but then i look at
the macro view and i'm gonna say this
has only been happening for such a small
amount of time in in humanity uh in
humanity's history of like
really looking at
how we affect each other and how our
emotions especially parent a child uh
affect the next generation you know
what's funny is i was just on the phone
with tom welling who was uh clark kent
on smallville for years with me who
i've never
well it's funny because i told him i
know him well i told him
i told him that i'm interviewing you and
he goes i like that guy goes but i i
gotta tell you i i never thought i mean
i never think he likes me i don't think
brandon likes me he said that i go do
you want me to tell him that he goes
yeah i just i don't think he i don't i
don't know what it is but i i don't know
i'm not sure if he likes me or not no
oh i don't like that um uh no i do i
actually do i really like tom in the in
the well i'm sad that he feels that way
but now he can feel hopefully
um better about that no
still listen he listens to all of them
uh that's what he tells you
i'm telling you he questions me about he
goes you should have hammered him so and
so more on that
no i i i i i appreciate and i enjoy our
time together when we've been to uh
several concerts together especially the
last one we did in england
um uh uh he's got great he's got he's
very charismatic
uh and i like his energy and uh no i i
like the dude i look forward to spending
uh more time more time with him we had
an interesting first uh meeting
tell me about it
and i and i never asked him about this
so we're we're like sending we're doing
this through you mean good this is good
do it through our first our first
meeting was
i just got in the role of superman
and superman returns
and
had never met him before and we're at
nike nike used to do this thing maybe
they still do where you go and
if you're you know you get a whole bunch
of free nike stuff right
um
and um
he was he was
scheduled to come
after me
now this building down in marina del rey
in california it's like oh well hang out
and say hi i'd like to meet him i never
met him before not even thinking like
what he might be thinking all i knew is
that maybe he didn't want to do that he
didn't want to play superman anymore
right i didn't know for sure right but
anyway we went down
and he's he's he gets out i think he's
attracted and i'm there with courtney
and i and uh
and uh the the
very kind woman from nike tracy
introduces us i say hey how you going
how you doing
for me i was like he doesn't like me
it was very it was a very short two-shot
they're very short they're like hey hey
how you doing yeah yeah uh yeah superman
ah cool okay uh see you later and that
was it
really that was it no congratulations no
nothing just kind of maybe he did maybe
he did all i remember was i thought he
didn't like me because then i became
because then i realized oh maybe i
shouldn't have maybe he didn't want to
say hi to me because he was having you
know mixed feelings about it right no
matter what he's played clark kent for
his whole life um
and pretty much pretty much and uh
you know i'm kind of forcing this
meeting so maybe i'm like the bat you
know maybe just like
and then and then finally i met him
again
at a year's year and years later at one
of the conventions like three years ago
maybe it was the first one we did
together in um
and uh
oklahoma right it could have been
oklahoma or something anywhere somewhere
anywhere
and he was
nice and cordial and and uh
and it erased that
you know that feeling because he
embraced he embraced me and didn't seem
like he had a problem and
um i have to look on the fact that he
doesn't think that i embraced him but no
i maybe there's that young feeling
well he you look tom he likes you
welling brandon likes you brandon tom
likes you that's just the way it is but
maybe there's something to be said about
you're both young
you just got the biggest part of your
life he just got the biggest part of his
life maybe there's an ego maybe
inadvertently it just feels like you
don't know how to act around each other
we all grow up years later you meet a
convention it's all like that now we've
done it what's up dude got it i'm an
adult now you're an adult because you
know people think you know what do you
think of jesse eisenberg what do you
think of the so-and-so i'm like hey
congratulations to him i'm thrilled for
him that he got you know lex luthor and
uh yeah but look is there
people will also say
do you get jealous do you get upset i'm
like
i don't get jealous about someone
getting a part
i get upset more resentful about not
being considered or auditioning or given
the opportunity to prove myself or so
that's the only thing i'll say but never
with an actor you can't i can't get
upset for someone they cast as lex
luther you know what i mean
totally
yeah the the biggest thing is like
is
consideration for being told
that this thing that involves a
character you've played in before is
happening that is in your world
that
um that
that people may weigh in and ask you
about and if you're surprised by it
and you don't know that this big thing
is happening
um
kind of speaking in very uh broad terms
but but it's just communication you know
it's communication about about the roles
that we care so much about yeah you know
i mean close to when you know when when
small was coming off the air and if
there was all that left stuff whatever
elect stuff might be happening
you know
you being in the know
since you've been the only person that
been lex for so long would be nice to
know so you're not blindsided by it i
think the industry can be they could be
cruel and they can be more uh what's the
word despondent i don't know if that's
the right word but just sort of
they neglect the idea of there's a
there's a certain respect and i think
everybody everybody who plays a role
you know we do we deserve
respect as do they as do the creators
and i think that you know it's like hey
the kid from smallville i don't even
know his name rose and bloomers or
whatever you know he's been playing lex
for a long time let's just have him come
in and read as a respectful thing just
have him come and read let's meet with
him
that's it even if you have no
thought of that's the only thing i would
say if like i was in a a higher
you know creative position
i would say hey you know brandon roth
was terrific in that let's just meet
with him let's just let him read let's
just test screen him let's why not he's
proven that he can do it that he looks
great that he's the part that he does it
it's just a sort of a respect that you
don't see a lot in the industry
that's all there's there's not like
there's a chip on my shoulder there's
not i love all these actors i work with
jesse and he's fantastic it's just a
matter it's it's more a creative thing
just hey read him
meet with him i think i think that in
maybe even comes down to
some courage you know on the behalf of
the the makers of whatever the project
is because
you know you might you you might
say you have you come in
they might be worried that you're going
to be upset with them and you're going
to yell at them and whatever uh you're
going to have your own reaction and they
can't they can't deal with it so they're
just like it's not even i'm going to
deal with that i don't look at that
thing just don't even consider it right
because i don't want to deal with the
actor's wrath you know
because we all have that we're all
successful in people like egotistical
actors who don't know anything
yeah um
you came back crisis on infinite earth
to play superman i know that was a that
was a big deal for you
that was a big did you get
i don't know i mean was there ever a
time where you got a little emotional
putting that suit back on oh for sure
absolutely really i mean yeah yeah i i
uh
thank goodness also because
yeah
you know the first time was such a
so much pressure and that i was trying
not to look at and also couldn't even
conceive of and i was like oh i'm gonna
do this i'm gonna get to and i'm gonna
appreciate the next one or i'm gonna you
know
relax into the next one i just have to
kind of get through this and
enjoy it but
i wouldn't have the awareness that i
have now and there was just great a lot
of gratitude for for having the
opportunity to to do this again for all
the parties that made it possible
um
and you know the i i've told the story
before but the first day that i came on
the set
uh i was shooting the bat
batwoman episode
and um his first time was appearing at
superman
in it
and i just was i thought this i've
already done it
like i've already i don't even if i even
if this was the only scene i'm doing
the emotional wound or scar
that was left from my experience of
returns was
was was mostly healed
because
all the lead up to that the costume
fitting the fan the wonderful warm
fan reaction people were excited and
appreciated having
me returned to the character
was validating and healing in so many
ways that being there was that first day
um was was the most magical of times and
and and
i was able to kind of relax and
appreciate the rest of the experience
from that moment i didn't have to prove
anything and i had nothing there was
nothing more to prove just being there
the fact that i had done that and read
the journey
not had the character for so long and
still was thought of i guess highly
enough or enough to to reprise even for
that a little bit was
was a validation i didn't know that i
needed
uh i guess um but it was very healing
did you did you think that
so there was no i thought of like how am
i going to play this guy because you
already played it right you already knew
what you were doing they didn't ask you
to
well in this world we want you to play
it a little differently or we want you
to be i mean was there any sort of
or just hey you or this guy just play
this guy again
no there was definitely there was
definitely um
some some considerations to be made it
is the same character but he's gone
through a lot since
superman returns um having lost lois
lane um and a lot of other other friends
killed by the joker um as you were kind
of mixing
um
uh uh
kingdom come storyline with the superman
returns backstory
in this so it's a different older more
mature
uh
superman and clark kell
um
then you had to play the angry uh
possessed
superman uh which is not something i'd
ever done before so i had to
tap into that and ground that so there
was definitely some challenges to to be
had and
and
tweaks to the character but i've been
thinking for a long time you know as i
as i had become a parent and matured and
started learn
more things about myself and
i was eager to bring that
wisdom to the character which
you know
i think is is there
not even when he's speaking but it's
kind of in the non-moving moments it's
kind of in the quiet moments where that
i think some of that stuff plays
what about the moments where you're
fighting tyler heckland
because those are pretty badass and i'm
watching some behind the scenes on some
clips and what was that like was that
fun did you guys have a lot of fun doing
that
uh uh
fun yes there was fun a lot of fun it's
hard because it's also
we only had one day
or very few days to do it you got to hit
your mark we're moving at a rapid pace
you don't want to hurt the other person
um
and
the the intense focus that you have to
have for some of that stuff
eliminates like
the super like it's all that the whole
thing is fun right we got to work with
the mix it's a mix of all that i had fun
i had more fun with the flying stuff
like so we shot at the separate parts
there's crashes the window and the
strangling stuff right and then
separately we did the wire work and that
was pretty cool
um and that was all one day too we did
so much work in one day i was astounded
by how much
all that technology has advanced but
that was cool i mean that was pretty
cool to to be flying together ish and
like fighting each other in the air that
was that was fun and cool what about
when you first put on the suit again the
very first day you put on the suit i
guess it's a fitting
and you walk into your trailer or
something you look in the mirror i mean
what was that feeling what was that
feeling well
there's
several variations of the fitting so you
go and you put on just the blue and then
they have the blue with the
the symbol that's not finished and
there's pins here still so
all of that was very cool but to be
finally kind of in it and parade around
i took many videos of it and what does
it look like when i'm running and if i
you know you know do a jump in slo-mo
um
it was very
uh
healing
and proud moment and just surreal why
healing you say healing
again it's that same thing uh
when i when i took on the role of
superman that's not something you take
on lightly
and i signed a three-picture deal and as
a 24 year old actor you're like oh i'm
going to do three movies this is going
to be successful
of course i'm going to be doing three
i'm going to be superman for for a while
now people are always going to know me
as a superman
had an amazing time making the first
movie
and then it comes out and you know it we
as everyone knows we did not do a sequel
so
anyways we talked
in our prior
uh interview was devastating yeah so
all those dreams all that that future
that i saw of myself as as superman in
multiple movies and then
all that would come from that
the uh the symbol and the role model
that i would be a superman and all that
stuff that i built up into my head as a
naive 24 year old
came crashing down
for all those years
and um
so to be in the suit again to be thought
of
and to be back in the suit again the
fans wanted you back the fans wanted you
back you know and to know that and to
know that was
you know you go to conventions and i uh
people would always tell me how much the
character meant to them i love hearing
that so much
but to have that fully realized that
energy matched with actually being in
the suit and going to film the thing
was
again like i said on the first day of
filming incredibly healing but being in
a suit again was was a full circle
a full circle moment which you i don't
know how many of those you get in in in
life um true
i was just really
present for that in in great
appreciation
for
a great appreciation you just look great
means so much to me you look great in
the suit too weren't you i mean
it really it really popped you just was
like yes this is this is superman it
just
it just it felt right did it
did it take a lot of fittings was there
anything that you were a little bit like
you know what i don't like this part
about the costume or can we was it was
the whole costume exactly what you
wanted you had no questions no uh
thoughts uh about any of it
i loved the superman return suit until i
got into this suit
and then and then i was like wow this is
you know a great appreciation for the
superman return suit and everyone who
worked so hard and thousands of hours to
make that suit
um but this suit is
this is
i love this i love uh
from the
the design you know it's mostly based on
uh
um alex's uh alex ross's ross art
and wonderful art you know there's not
much that's different from what he from
what he
his his
all of his stuff um but it just felt
powerful and
simple
the cape was lighter it was like this
new material so it flew that floated
and glided and i'd have like this weight
pulling me back um i love the shorts
the cut that was great
um because i don't like superman without
underpants i'm sorry i agree with you
hey
strange to me
um the s was bigger which was a lot of
people's problem with the superior turns
i thought it filled out the chest great
and the muscle suit the guys made
everybody guys everybody every superhero
has a muscle suit underneath there um
whether they say it or not everyone does
um
and this one just it it it was shaped
just great i made you know i had i had a
different shape um after 15 years of
weight training since then my body was
different and more
more of a superman shape also in a way
so
they
amplified and
helped me where i needed it
[Music]
yeah i love it i think people assume
that oh they've got the body suit they
don't have to be in great shape that's
not true is it you gotta you gotta fit
you gotta fill it out um you have to
fill it out still because it's still
it's still padding and most of most of
the muscles some of the places where
people need help
are there's more there's more pad but
some places it's like this and it's like
this so they can make a groove so you
can see the bicep
um
definition when they're just standing
still right because an actor can't sit
there and be flexed the whole time
they'd never you'll never be able to
hear anything they're saying because
they're doing this the whole time
they're sweating and they would get
tired and there's only so many push-ups
you can do in a day to pump up right you
know you're doing a shirtless scene you
get on
the floor you do push-ups and you do
some bicep curls and you do your
shirtless scene
but you're in a suit all day you can't
do that so it's
it's imperative
that you have
that uh underneath that body suit muscle
zoo whatever you want to call it to help
you look like a superhero all the time
even when you're standing still right so
that's why everyone has them
jason momoa is huge zach is huge henry
cavill was huge i was huge
for your own body body body type
but
in order to it's a movie it's not
reality you have to make those things
those accommodations
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at better help better help
online therapy boy i can't tell you how
much this works i get emails all the
time thank you for talking about better
help thank you for getting me into to
therapy
ryan does better help i do
i just you know uh i just had a friend
this morning i was facetiming with him
and his wife said you know my kid's uh
dealing with depression
and uh do you know any good therapist i
go better help online therapy because
they're in the middle of sort of nowhere
and you don't need to go anywhere you
can facetime or text or you know it's
it's better help is just uh it's amazing
it just helped you out yeah it's uh it's
convenient
yeah it has been good i have gotten a
lot out of it well i like that look
whether you're struggling with grief
relationships or stress or having
trouble sleeping or meeting goals online
therapy might be for you better help is
secure online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with a
licensed professional
therapists betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
accredited therapist you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
therapists have a broad range of
expertise which may not be available in
your area
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime folks
send a message to your therapist you'll
get timely and thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
you need and that may happen you know
you meet someone the first time you may
not vibe with them you change your
therapist better help it's that easy
and i i completely recommend this
so many people have told me it works
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy by a landslide if you
ask me and financial aid is available
visit betterhelp.com
inside and join over the 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help ryan
that they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states
inside of you is sponsored by betterhelp
and our listeners get 10 off their first
month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside give it a shot
better help inside of you is brought to
you by sonos my good friends sonos how
much do i love these guys at sonos you
love this it is this is by far if you're
going to get a good holiday gift this is
a great
holiday gift sono devices are all around
my house i've had them for years i've
said this before but before i even had
them as sponsors which they were they're
just recently sponsors uh i've always
loved sonos i talk about it with
everybody and people are like
people everywhere have sonos
and um i'm not the only one that loves
this product they just make great
products and you know instead of having
receivers and speakers everywhere in
your house you can just have this little
device that has beautiful sound and
that's really what sonos is about if you
ask me it's like uh you know saving
space it's not the old days where you
need to have five receivers and a
turntable and this all that you know
it's like come on man uh sonus is
wonderful make the sound system on your
wish list a reality share the joy of
listening on sonos this season with
speakers and sound bars that are easy to
set up easy to use and all work together
so you can listen in any or every room
like i do and bring the family together
with incredible sound for everything
from classic carols to festive films
sonos works with all your streaming
services and control is simple with the
sonos app your voice using amazon alexa
or google assistant and apple airplay 2.
spoil the listeners in your life folks
with a gift that truly keeps on giving
treat gamers and movie lovers to an
immersive home theater experience with
the beam
keep your fitness loving friends
motivated with great sound for their
workout playlist with move and help
relatives relax with hand-free control
of their music and more on sonosuan you
won't be sorry i'm gonna get ready to be
bombarded with emails because you're
gonna tell me how much you love sonos
that is just a fact i love them i know
you'll love them it's a great holiday
gift go to sonos.com it's sonos.com
to learn more and wrap up your holiday
shopping
how was it i know you're you're coming
back right for an episode of the flash
um
superman is right you're superman no
yeah adam oh that's ray palmer yes
so he's coming back in in a flash
episode coming out relatively soon the
september november 19th i think it's the
beginning of they're doing like a mini
mini crossover first five episodes of
flash and so rey and the adam are in the
first
uh the first episode right and you did
the 100th episode right 100th episode of
legends yep and now how now how was that
like um
finding out like they're like hey we're
not going to um have your character
return in legends was that i mean did
they do you right did they approach you
right did they tell you that this is
going to end in the
in the way you wanted to hear it is
there a way you want to hear it
you mean what you know when we were done
on season five yeah
well we i mean we we we we talked about
that i don't think i talked at length
about that in our last oh yes you did
you did by the way i won't go back into
that um
uh and that's been
uh
you know the last two years and pandemic
and all that everything happening in the
world there's been a lot of time to
reflect and and process that whole
experience
uh
and um ultimately it's been a journey
for me of learning uh and appreciating
and uh
cultivating my own self-worth yeah well
they keep bringing you back so it's not
like the women like you and and uh you
know people make decisions right people
make some people sometimes people make
good decisions and sometimes people make
bad decisions right um bad decisions
happen all the time all the time um
all the time
and sometimes they affect us uh
negatively and we can choose to be upset
with that for the rest of our lives or
we can work to
come to terms with it i guess
and to find as they say make
lemonade
out of lemons
um
and you know that's what that's what
i've been working on doing and i think i
speak for courtney and saying the same
thing
um and knowing meanwhile by fan reaction
and all the love we've gotten over the
last couple years that
even though one person made this
decision that was a bad decision um
nobody supports that
right nobody has supported that decision
um
uh and uh and so that's one reason why
one of the reasons why we said yes to
come back because
i
we knew that it would it would be
the fans would appreciate it
um and also we
you know
we
we made sure that in coming back
that we would be
that we were standing in our own worth
and and made our own
uh requests
to
make sure that we were
felt like
we were being respected yes and that
happened this time around so yeah we
were happy to be a a part of it and uh
and also to get an opportunity to work
again with with wentworth
uh and and victor and faulk uh some
people who who in france also who didn't
have as much opportunity to be in the
the season four energy of legends kind
of more goofy open so it was fun to kind
of play with them in that new sandbox
that the show had become where it wasn't
it wasn't that way as much when they
started out you know it comes back to
respect like you said that you felt like
when you went back you respected i think
that you know a lot of people don't know
but i'm sure they do when they asked me
to do crisis on infinite earth um
you know it was more like we don't have
a script this is all you're getting and
that's it and you're gonna either get
say yes or no and i was like well how
could i say yes to that there's like
absolutely zero respect there's no
script there's no money there's no
nothing so i had no choice
to come back but it sounds to me like
they were like hey we're treating
brandon with respect we're treating him
right then we're going to take care of
them
we made sure that
we
that that was happening good i like i
like that i'm glad you took care of that
uh what what is the truth of uh a ray
palmer uh adam spin-off series i know
there was some early talks with berlanti
about that but that never kind of uh
materialized uh i mean uh uh obviously
i'm always open to that um no one has
spoken to me about it uh
except for me internally going to be a
good joke um
um but i love ray palmer and love to
continue uh
playing
ray palmer what's the the maybe it's
just uh hearsay but uh is it the role of
superman they were talking about maybe
an hbo series potentially or any further
talks about that or anything like that
did you hear about that
uh i mean i've heard of very kind people
on twitter and people tweeting me okay
so it's the same sort of people it's not
anybody of like you know yeah i mean i i
have i have uh
i am i am interested in that type of a
situation so i've kind of i have i have
um
floated questions and uh
but you know there's a lot going on with
superman right now there are several
projects already uh uh
[Music]
far along at hbo and at warner brothers
um
so
and with tyler you know doing kicking
ass uh on on superman of lois um there's
not
there's a lot of superman that's gonna
be happening right now so many superman
you know maybe maybe in a few years it's
a possibility i never say no to anything
these days because of what happened yeah
so um so
uh you know i have i have
i have
i have positive thoughts that um there
may be a reprisal again someday uh
of my superman i mean so what to what
extent i don't know right the rookie
with uh nathan fillion how how much do
you enjoy doing that
that was interesting i love nathan uh
he's been a friend for a while and and
he called up and said uh during the
middle of the pandemic said hey would
you like a job said yes
uh that's not what he said but that's
that's what i received um and they said
oh it's this you know i'd love to have
you come on this is you know
nice arc on on our show
we want to play against type
um
it's this cop who we kind of think is an
okay guy but then
he's he's a
pretty racist uh police officer and we
we realized you know this you know
through the course of his arc i said wow
let me think about that
um and i thought you know this is
of the moment it's something uh top of
it needs to be talked about and
discussed and that's what i want you
know when i'm sometimes sometimes you
play characters that are just fun
and it's just to give people an escape
from the day and sometimes you play
stuff that is important for the social
moving the social uh uh
agenda forward and sometimes you're the
bad guy part of that right so i took it
as a great opportunity for that to learn
to grow as an actor
um and to
to see how i could do uh to to play that
role so yeah it's hard to jump in too
it's hard jumping into something that's
already like a success right yeah they
were in their third season
and doing great and then it was
peak pandemic like
face shields masks testing three times a
week
you can't even uh really hard to meet
anybody and to have
create that camaraderie on set which i
so much appreciate right that's one of
the my favorite things about being on
set is creating that film family
tv family so it took longer to kind of
initiate that or to to to grow that but
uh all the they were great cast and crew
and had a lot of fun working with all of
them what's magic the card game because
uh my engineer ryan kind of geeked out a
little bit he's like oh yeah of course
he kind of geeked out
magic the gathering yeah i did magic the
gathering what did i say what did i say
magic the card game magic the card game
why did i say that i don't know magic
the japanese you don't play magic the
gathering yes magic the gathering tell
me about magic the gathering
uh well it's a
it's a card game that's been around for
more than 20 years 25 30 years
i started playing when i was 16. i think
i remember buying my first pack at the
iowa state fair i was uh
i was i was on a break
um from uh making corn dogs
at um the corn dog stand and i worked it
for the
ten days in the summer
and uh i bought a i bought a i bought a
a couple packs and like a deck uh
pre-made deck um and i was just
fascinated by the whole thing for for
years but there was never i didn't have
enough there were never enough people
around me to play
um but i always enjoyed it and then my
cousin and so i have
thousands of cards
you know collection and uh anyway so
they
asked uh to do a voice um for the new
animated series coming on netflix next
year um so it's a cool thing excited to
be a part of so cool when you get to be
excited about some you get to be a part
of something that you're already excited
about and your your child will probably
be excited about leo i i think he's not
into magic yet but uh he's only nine so
you know maybe there's there's time
there's time yeah
uh how is it working with your wife i
mean how much do you like working with
your wife especially like in the
crossover and doing all these things
what was that like
i i love it um
we
have
you know we've done i can't even lose
track of how many projects we've done
together four or five
um and uh
you know we have a relaxed
relaxed energy because we know we can
trust each other so that allows us
especially in comedy to to play to
create new moments uh a lot of the magic
that's in legends of tomorrow in our
episodes um is stuff that we're we're
talking about at home before we get
there or we say what if we did this or
it's just happening on the moment and i
know that she's so skilled and talented
that she's gonna roll with it if i do
something
you know
um
little stuff where we're walking down
the hallway sneaking onto the ship and
um
she doesn't know where she's going so
she goes one way and i go the other way
bump into each other and it's like an
awkward you know silly physical comedy
moment yeah just small things but that
just had to
add to it um and so that makes it really
fun to be able to to come to work to
know that i can
rely on my scene partner and i don't
have to i don't also i don't have to do
as much work yeah and the fact that you
get along with her it's good that you
get along
yes
do you think leah will ever want to act
has he ever thought about it has he ever
talked to you about like dad i want to
play a character uh yeah i mean you know
we got puppets we've he's made various
movies of different genres yeah
storyboards
i've written
stories that he's dick i you know he's
dictating and i'm
writing it down uh
he we did this thing for quibby before
it went away with uh jason wrightman who
had us do you know the
princess bride
home movie homemade princess bride thing
that we did and he asked courtney to be
a part of it and then we enlisted leo to
be an ros
um a rat of unusual size crawling to the
fire swarm so that's his first role he's
credited with on imdb no lines but uh i
think growling uh and then i did this it
just is up here one of the things i'm
doing up here is this hallmark movie
sequel to this christmas hallmark movie
i did in 2014.
and uh this big christmas
scene santa
photo op thing and uh
we have practiced with leo a little bit
like stand on the line and say stand on
the tape here's your mark and say you're
lying because he's talked about wanting
to to be an actor and
um say well you have to go to class you
have to learn how to do stuff and you
have to listen to the director
um
anyway
so we've kind of been preparing him if
he wants to continue you know look into
it more but we got a he's an he's an
extra anyway in the movie i got him a a
little thing in the movie so in the
movie so um
which i think will stay in the cut
uh and i love those he was so he was so
excited he was more excited
than we knew he was going to be he was
so excited about it he did an
awesome job and it was just so cool even
though i don't have dialogue with him or
but i see him in the scene i'm not in
the scene with him and it's that's my
son over there
it was such a trippy surreal cool
cool thing so yeah who knows if he'll do
more
but he's going to be in film and
television seems like
in some arts the capacity whatever it
manifests into as he grows i don't know
i have to ask you i didn't ask you about
this but the christina aguilera video i
mean just [ __ ] for shits and giggles i
mean how was she to be on set with and
it was just i mean you were how old were
you i was when i first came out here i
was
21. so it had to be kind of exciting
she's a big singer at that point
yeah i didn't even know i i didn't know
who she was what i i just heard the song
on the radio um and then
it was like modeling i got to my
modeling agency at the time modeling
casting call
you know i wasn't the lead guy i was
i wasn't i wasn't the lead guy like her
boyfriend i was one of the
badly
dancing
guys on the sideline right but that was
the first
i wasn't the first i had done one
episode of tv before that but this was
kind of a cool like hip hip thing
and
uh
she was fine she was very she was very
new to it too so she was kind of quiet
and sticking to herself i think it's a
lot for her i think it was only the
first or second music video that she'd
done right and i didn't really i didn't
really ever chat to her because it was
fun you like doing one of like 30 other
other guys but it was fun and cool i
thought it was a pretty neat thing um
to be a part of and a funny thing
certain to to look back and say oh
there's my arm oh there's my face but
there's
dancing
do you think would you love to just
somebody to say brandon i want you to
gain like 20 pounds and just be a fat
schlub in a movie i don't want you to be
the good looking
ripped up brandon i don't want you to be
this the cop brandon or the superman
brandon the ray palmer i want you to be
schlubby brandon you're looking at me
like you don't really like that
just not healthy
it's just not
uh there's not a really healthy way to
do that well i know too much i know too
much about health
health in the body and and uh
damage to the body that you know the
pandemic was bad enough i bet my
schlubbiest during the pandemic uh you
know
leo had to do his
his eighth um
you know annual well-child annual visit
with a doctor on the zoom and
we needed to weigh him
and we didn't have a scale we didn't
didn't have it we don't believe in like
the need for scales um
it's fine to have one but anyway we just
didn't have one so we bought one on
amazon
and we get it and i'm trying and i step
on it i'm like
i don't think this is right it's recap
or calibrated this is like 15 pounds off
courtney gets on the scale she's like
yeah it's like at least like 10 pounds
off i go yeah it's
broken or something in the shipping so i
go in and get a 25 pound weight and i
put it on there
25 pounds
scale's not broken i have gained 15
15 pounds right and that's being kind um
because i wasn't sure where i started
out
um
but i was in like some of the best shape
of my life coming off of
re
returning as superman right and then
fast forward and a year later
and i then i was like then every time i
looked in the mirrors like oh yeah no
those are
that's that's that's weight you swelled
up you swelled up put on some weight it
just took a while right um and i didn't
i didn't really like it
so i've been you know
been more active lately and shedding
some of that and getting back into uh a
better fighting weight right but i don't
know yeah i don't i would maybe it
depends on the director depends on the
project look if it's an amazing thing
and i have to i you know i'd make it
work or get just you know get the the
the large suit the larger suit yes uh to
to do that kind of stuff uh this is this
is called [ __ ] talking with brandon
ralph this wraps us up these are rapid
fire uh you might be feel like you're a
little redundant in answering these
questions but so be it um
misha h did you like playing two roles
on a crossover
i did it was very
awesome experience was it difficult
it was difficult just in that i had to
make sure that there was a difference
between ray and clark right and
uh between the atom and superman
which i knew there was but i had never
had to like analyze it because i had to
then do i had to show my picture double
the mannerisms and the physicality while
if we were both in the same scene so
that he could do play me while i was
playing me right right right uh nico p
what was the feedback like after your
last appearance on the inside of you
podcast did you get a lot of a good
feedback on that yeah i did yeah
absolutely people um very uh thankful
for some of the things that i opened up
about and discussed and um
uh
yeah
good it was nice to hear that that was
you know that sharing that kind of stuff
was
was helpful yeah absolutely i'd love to
have you love having you again scott j
did you find it refreshing to play a
darker and morally ambiguous character
in the rookie after playing so many good
upbeat characters in the past i mean you
sort of answered that but ultimately
yeah i don't know if it was i think
about refreshing i think i feel i feel
like
i leveled up a little bit there's things
i could have done differently and with
that role too relaxing into it and just
like
fully embracing him more um
but uh but only ultimately i feel good
in that i that i learned some valuable
some valuable things as an actor and as
a person
tom and which brandon's favorite item to
sign at a convention for the fans oh
favorite item to sign at a convention
huh i don't know uh i like signing um
people bring in
like the the s shield oh yeah uh those
are kind of cool or like when it's a big
statue sometimes they bring in just the
plate the base of the statue yep um
those are kind of cool and challenging
to sign do you have dolls or figures at
your house that you like when superman
came out or even from flash or you know
just like the crossovers and legends do
you have action figures
yeah i mean we have the action figures
they're not on display or anything we
haven't quite gotten to the point where
we're
we don't have a space in our house to
really do that adequately we don't i
don't have like a trophy room um
maybe someday in the house we will do
something like that but but they i have
them around and usually what what's
happened is leo's playing with them and
they lose an arm uh you know especially
adam stuff
courtney courtney has stuff of her too
from uh from uh
the fault from fallout uh oh three we
should have voiced for and she says
pop uh norah stuff too but anyway that's
awesome bob k last question favorite
classic film you would remake and star
in
i mean
it could even be a favorite movie of
yours yeah uh
um
braveheart is my favorite movie
nice what a good one you know i don't
know that i could do that role justice
uh but also let's see what else like um
money python and holy grail i would love
to be
you'd love to remake that and be a part
in that one one one scene in that i
don't know who i would be but work on my
british accent i'd be the knight
you know that when he can't cross and he
cuts his
your freaking arms off i'll kick you to
death i'll black knight yeah the black
knight i i played the black knight that
would be fun um why not
this has been a blast i i love talking
to you you're so open
forthcoming and um like you said i'm
like people said i think people really
enjoy hearing your stories and
hearing the truth hearing you know just
like you know how you're feeling and how
you're doing and ultimately i think you
know it just sounds like you got your
[ __ ] together and you're you're working
and you're enjoying life and you're
enjoying the kid and your family
yeah you know working on it all the time
i still slip up uh more than i want as
far as you know
being the best communicator and always
you know working to be a better teammate
better dad
uh
a better cast mate um
you know
i think one thing i'm learning on
learning about is this is
is
is his boundaries
creating better boundaries and
expectations for myself and what other
people have expectations for me and
coming on here and being a part of this
uh
and not uh
trying to evangelize but just you know
speak my truth straight shooter my man
straight shooter always always
appreciates it well thanks for coming on
the podcast again i appreciate you
allowing me to be inside of you again
this has been fantastic i can't wait to
actually hang with you and uh you know
you're in vancouver right now right yes
and you're filming
uh i finished filming for now um and um
possible things brewing of being
somewhere else but i might just stay up
here it feels nice and safe and insane
and you're a little sane in the old cube
yeah all right all my love to you man
and i hope to see you soon thanks all
right buddy good to see you good to see
you of course
you know ryan you can just tell that you
know brandon's a genuinely
good guy
oh yeah he you could just tell he's a
good dad he's a good husband he tries
he tries hard he listens he's matured
um
when i listened to guys like him
or guests like him
i i you know you want to be a better
person i feel like god this guy's a good
guy and uh i always wish him the best
and he's got such a great attitude and
he just talks about you know the reality
of it all how you do get down you do get
depressed you do get anxious you do
you're not happy with the way things are
going sometimes and um that's life man
that's freaking life how cool is it we
had two
back-to-back supermen
superman and the week before you had a
super girl
you know you had for someone from
supergirl so we're ending the season
with uh supergirl
and uh super duper and wait and the
super duper way to end the year so thank
you brandon thank you tom willing thank
you ozzy to spy
and encourage you to donate this year if
you haven't uh echoesofhope.org
for foster youth
foodonfoot.org for the homeless
situation
in los angeles
the homeless situation not the
homelessness situation yeah homelessness
homeless
yes
foodonfoot.org and uh the ronald
mcdonald house is always a beautiful
thing to donate to um thank you for all
my lovely patrons for the year who've
supported the podcast i've talked about
you all the time because without you i
couldn't do it
and um so thank you if you want to join
patreon the wonderful family to give
back to the show a little more if you
feel like you can that's great if not
thank you for just listening patreon.com
inside of you um also the inside of you
online store he's got some great stuff
for the holidays and uh smallville stuff
and autographs and just plenty of stuff
out there and also sunspin.com if you
want to have a zoom with me
and um uh also get some cool swag for
the band sunspin because you see stephen
amell and tom welling always wear the
sunspin hats the sunspend shirts i
[ __ ] i like it that's cool
that's nice of them to do that
anything else ryan
no man you don't got anything anything
you want to say for the end of the year
before we wrap this up
man i hope the next one
is better i hope we just keep getting
better i think that's important you just
said we need to keep getting we as a
society we just need to be good to each
other it's not that hard hey
open a door for someone
an act of kindness
it costs nothing to be kind costs
nothing to be kind it's harder to be an
[ __ ]
that is
ask me i'll tell you
i've been an [ __ ] before i'm sure
uh let's get into the top tiers these
are people who give back
more than they have to for sure these
are the top tier patrons again if you
want to join patreon patreon.com inside
of you uh let's see how many you
remember ryan let's do it nancy d leah
sarah v little lisa you kiko jill e
brian h nico p jerry w robert
b
jason w kristen k emilia oh allison raj
c joshua d emily
f
s
s correct cj p samantha m jennifer l
n and correct stacy
l
correct
jen
um
if her hudson
you get five wrongs and you're done so
jen what
i don't know gen b gen s jamal f correct
janelle
b correct kimberly
e mike
w that's your first one you've missed
your second no leanne
there might have been a couple f's that
i disguised as esses and vice versa
maybe uh leanne
p correct janine
r maya p maddie s belinda
and chris
h
dave
spider-man chase sheila g brad d ray h
tabitha t mr
oh
[ __ ]
mr michael mr m i'll give you that one
all right liliana m
n
a a correct michelle
okay correct michael
[Music]
go with whatever you think d no s that's
your second wrong talia
n
m m
i'll give you i'll give you that one
you're so close betsy
uh d correct laura
a
no l and chad
l correct rochelle nathan
b e
all right you got two more x's
marion sorry marion hi meg k
janelle
b
p
correct
trav l dan
uh
s n all right you got one more miss and
we're done but you've gotten through
quite a few big stevie w angel
uh
m that's correct rhiannon c
corey
d
k [ __ ] super
sam coleman g dev nexon michelle
k
no they already that one i don't know
guess
a all right
now that's it so this is i'll read the
rest but you missed five but you got
through quite a big chunk
liz i jeremy c andy t cody r sebastian k
gav mineter gavinator david c john b
brandy d yvore camille asks the c
joey m willie f christina e adelaide and
omar i lena n eugene and leah chris p
nikki g corey patricia heather l and
jake b
you did really well dude
it started to slip a little bit but it's
it's not easy it's like you're trying to
put a name and and there's it's just i
couldn't do it i couldn't do these names
i couldn't do it
there's a couple missing which is bummer
but uh there's a couple new ones which
are fun yeah who's missing
tab of the 272 not to be confused
tab with the 273. that's correct yeah
she went away but we love her yeah all
the support and love that's right
anybody who who is a top tier whether
you're a top tier for a month or top
tier for a year
the support is overwhelming so thank you
thank you for listening to the inside of
you with michael rosenbaum
uh it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
did you just shatner your own theme song
i just chattered it he shattered all
over it
uh i love you ryan thank you for being
here happy new year to you happy new
year to you happy new year jason the
editor you rock buddy happy new year
bryce happy new year cumulus
uh continue to listen man next year's
gonna be a great year remember january
4th we have off but we're back and we're
going to come in strong and i've got
some great news coming your way for the
new year that you're going to love so
stay tuned thank you for allowing me to
be inside of each and every one of you
from michael rosenbaum here in the
hollywood hills of california ryan hayes
also here in the hollywood hills
california giveaway to the camera ryan
bye we love you guys uh be good to
yourselves happy happy happy new year
[Music]